pues el presidente celebro que más de 15
millones de personas hayan votado por
que permanezca en la presidencia dijo
que son más votos de los que consiguió
en 2006 felipe calderón su oponente a
pesar del fraude dijo que se orquestó
también son más votos de los que obtuvo
el candidato del par en 2018 ricardo
anaya por lo que pues se mostró contento
con esta participación no obstante dijo
que si no hubo más gente votando fue por
un boicot del instituto electoral que
puso sólo un tercio de las casillas que
corresponden a una elección federal en
respuesta el instituto electoral en su
presidente lorenzo córdova dijo que el
boicot en todo caso fue contra el
instituto ya que le recortaron el
presupuesto y por ello no pudo instalar
tal cantidad de casillas la oposición en
tanto pues bueno calificó como un
rotundo fracaso el que 15 millones de
personas menos hayan votado por un lópez
obrador que en 2018 cuando obtuvo 30
millones de sufragios a su favor por lo
que dijo a pesar de la operación de
estado y de todas las trampas que dijo
se hicieron desde el gobierno no un
subjetivo marido y tras esta consulta el
presidente volvió a tocar el tema de la
reforma electoral que responda o que
propondrá al congreso que también
modificaría los referendos revocatorios
que detalles compartió al respecto
así es bueno además de insistir en que
los consejeros a través de esta reforma
que propone serán elegidos directamente
por el pueblo para acabar con las cuotas
partidistas señaló que toda vez que se
tendrá entonces un consejo confiable
podrán entonces pensar en instalar la
votación electrónica